مرحبًا بك مرة أخرى في البرنامج ، أعلم
أنك لن تخوض في الكثير من
التفاصيل العسكرية ، ولكن ماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا أننا
نكتب أنك تحقق مكاسب إضافية ،
انظر كريستيانو آسف ، لن أكون
أكثر تفصيلاً حقًا أه هذا هو  أه
موضوعي المتكهن أه أه أه في العديد من
وسائل الإعلام سأقول لك سأكرر
رئاستي فقط وأقول إن بعض
الإجراءات المضادة بالفعل
جارية أه لن نرسل فقط
بالتأكيد ليس الأمر علنًا في
الأماكن المحددة وما هي المكاسب
قال رئيسي إنك ستشعر بها أه
بالتأكيد وأضاف أيضًا أن
مزاج القادة العسكريين
المسؤولين عن هذه العمليات
إيجابي جدًا وأنت تعلم أه عندما يكون مزاج
الجنرالات إيجابيًا يمكنك الاعتماد على
نتائج واعدة جدًا لذا دعني أسأل  أنت
لأنه كما قلنا إن الأمين
العام لحلف الناتو في واشنطن للقاء
الرئيس بايدن وسيعقد
هذه الاجتماعات غدًا ومن الواضح أن
حالة الحرب
ستظهر حالة المواد التي يوفرها الناتو ، ونحن نفهم أن هناك
الكثير من المركبات الأمريكية مثل
برادلي فايتنج على سبيل المثال
التي دمرها الروس في
الموجة الأولى من الهجوم المضاد ،
أطلب منك هذا من حيث محاولة
فهم
كيف أن كل ما تم إعطاؤه لك حتى
الآن يمكن قياسه
حسنًا ، حسنًا ، أنت بالتأكيد تفهم
أهمية دور المواد الغربية أو
الغربية أه الأسلحة والذخيرة
التي هي في أمس الحاجة إليها في أوكرانيا نحن
عند التحضير للهجوم المضاد نحن
حقًا أه أنت تعلم أه أردنا أن يكون هذا المستوى
من الذخيرة والأسلحة بكمية
كافية  الكمية لكنك
تفهم بالتأكيد عندما تكون في حالة حرب ، فأنت تعلم أنك تعرف أن
لديك الذخيرة في مكان ما
في المستودعات أو أن المدفعية في
مكان ما في المخزونات كانت تستخدمها ،
فنحن نستخدمها عند الدفاع عن
أراضينا في الشرق كنا نستخدمها
من قبل عندما كنا  كنا نواجه
هجومًا مضادًا حول Hardeep و
Hearthstone وسنستخدمهما
وبالتأكيد سنحتاج إلى المزيد من
أجل تحقيق النجاحات أه
يجب أن يكون الهجوم المضاد ناجحًا
وسيعني النجاح
تحرير أكبر عدد
ممكن من الأراضي الأوكرانية و  نعم لذلك
سنحتاج إلى المزيد من المدفعية
والذخيرة ، نعم سنحتاج إلى المزيد من
دبابات القتال والمركبات المدرعة ، نعم في
المراحل اللاحقة سنحتاج بالتأكيد إلى
الطائرات المقاتلة التي نتحدث معك
قبل اجتماع رامشتاين هذا الأسبوع ،
لذا سيكون مهمًا للغاية
لوزراء الدفاع لاتخاذ
قرارات ملموسة بشأن تقديم المزيد من هذا
النوع من الأسلحة إلى بلدي من
أجل إنجاح هذا الهجوم المضاد ،
لذلك من المثير للاهتمام حقًا أن
الهدف هو
استعادة أكبر قدر ممكن من الأراضي
لأنه كان في الماضي  كان واضحًا جدًا
أنك تريد استعادة كل
شبر أخير من الأراضي بما في ذلك شبه جزيرة القرم وفيما
يتعلق بهذه الأمور ، قال
وزير دفاعك في رامشتاين ،
وزير دفاعك ،
أم ريزنيكوف ، إن توقع
هذا الهجوم المضاد مبالغ
فيه ، حيث ينتظره معظم الناس
شيء ضخم أود أن أقوله إنه
شاغلي الرئيسي هو مقدار الضغط الذي تشعر به
هو أنه محموما ، ما الذي
تعرفه على أنه النجاح في هذا
الهجوم المضاد
مرة أخرى هذه ليست أول
عملية هجوم مضاد كنا
نواجهها وبالتأكيد ربما  لن
تكون آخر عملية هجوم مضاد
أه الهدف النهائي
للهجوم المضاد كعملية هي
استعادة كل الأراضي بما في ذلك شبه
جزيرة القرم لذلك هنا لا يمكن أن يكون لديك أي
تكهنات وأي شكوك وهذا هو
الهدف النهائي لأه  بالنسبة
للحملة العامة
للإجابة العامة المضادة ، كما
نتحدث الآن ، يمكنهم إنشاء عملية
ومرة ​​أخرى لن أشيد بكم على
المكان الذي تجري فيه هذه العملية ، لذا
من الواضح أن الجزء الذي تجري فيه هذه العملية
المحررة
وكذلك الأجزاء الأخرى من
الأراضي الأوكرانية يجب أن يتم تحريرها بما في ذلك شبه
جزيرة القرم ، لكن يمكنني أن أوافق على أنك
تعلم أن هذه
التكهنات محمومة لأنك
قد تتذكر أن أول شخص
أعلن عن
الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني هذه المرة كان
الرئيس  من الغريب أن بوتين
لم يعلن عن نزعته المضادة ولكن عن
هجوم أوكرانيا المضاد ، لذا كان
اتجاهًا مثيرًا للاهتمام ، ولكن مرة أخرى
يسعد كريستيانا لتجنب أي
تكهنات وسوء فهم ، فإن
الهدف النهائي
لحملة الهجوم المضاد في أوكرانيا هو
استعادة جميع أراضي أوكرانيا
بما في ذلك  القرم وعندما نسمع
شركاءنا الذين يقولون إننا
سنقف مع أوكرانيا طالما استغرق الأمر وعندما
نسمع من شركائنا
فقط السلطة الأوكرانية
الرئيس الأوكراني الشعب الأوكراني هو الذي
سيناقش تحديد نطاق الانتصار الذي
نتفق معه  هذا الأوكرانيون
أوكرانيا سوف يكون لديهم فهم
النصر النهائي بالنسبة لنا ، من
الواضح جدًا تحرير جميع أراضي
أوكرانيا.